vous aimez bien ce chat moi aussi il me
fait penser aux chats que j'avais quand
j'étais petit regardez comme ils
allèrent relâché détendu il étire ses
pattes
moi j'étais toujours fasciné par le fait
qu'un chat quand il tombe d'une certaine
hauteur la plupart du temps ils arrivent
à retomber sur ses pattes essence les
casser ce n'est pas comme nous les
humains on a les eaux bien plus fragile
vous connaissez sans doute quelqu'un
parmi vos amis ou dans votre famille qui
s'est déjà cassé un os ou qui a eu un
tassement des vertèbres ici à grenoble
on peut dire qu'on est particulièrement
bien placé pour les accidents montagne
le vtt le ski le parapente
mais la perte d'offre elle peut aussi
venir des cancers et du vieillissement
qu'il ya des facteurs aggravants
notamment le tabac le diabète des
infections qui font que nous osons vont
mal se réparer dans la plupart des cas
bon je vous rassure nos eaux ils vont
s'auto réparer il faut juste
s'immobiliser puis attendre quelques
semaines voire quelques mois
mais il arrive dans 5 à 10 % des cas que
nous on n'arrive pas à se réparer
dans ce cas là il y a besoin de trouver
des méthodes pour aider nos eaux à se
réparer
je suis scientifique je travaille et je
dirige une équipe dans le domaine des
biomatériaux quand j'étais adolescente
mon rêve c'était travailler dans la
recherche biomédicale et maintenant ma
passion c'est de développer des
technologies innovantes pour aider les
médecins à réparer nos organes ça
s'appelle la médecine régénérative le
but de la médecine régénérative et de
régénérer nos organes qui sont faits de
tissus
on peut citer le cartilage
hélas dans le cas dans les cas
difficiles de fractures osseuses
la première chose que vous faire les
chirurgiens c'est de faire une greffe
d'os dans ce cas ils vont prendre un
bout d'os chez les patients dans le dans
l'os de la crête iliaque qu'ils vont
aller mettre à la place du défaut au ce
c'est une procédure qui se fait mais qui
présente deux inconvénients majeurs
d'une part on a une quantité de ce qui
est limité et d'autre part c'est une
procédure qui est douloureuse pour le
patient depuis à peu près une
quarantaine d'années il ya tout un tas
d'un plan qui ont été développés par les
ingénieurs et qui sont maintenant
utilisée couramment en chirurgie que ce
soit en orthopédie en maxillo-faciale et
puis aussi si vous réfléchissez bien
chez votre dentiste
alors je sais pas à quoi vous pensez si
je vous dis un plan moi une des
premières choses qui me vient à l'esprit
c'est une prothèse de hanche
puisque tout mon temps à ma maman elle
en a une aussi
enfin tout le monde pas tout le monde
mais beaucoup de personnes désormais et
puis on peut citer aussi davis pour
réparer des fractures j'ai mis ici une
petite image d'une cage qu'on peut
mettre dans la colonne vertébrale ou
encore des petites granules qu'on va
mettre dans le trou au ce les implants
apporte une certaine tenue mécanique
ils vont être vraiment très intéressant
pour réparer l'os mais dans certaines
situations vraiment critique
ils ne vont pas suffire car ils sont
inertes
au mieux ils vont interagir avec notre
corps
dans ces cas là il va falloir trouver
une solution plus puissante
cette solution c'est une molécule
bioactives une molécules bioactives elle
va interagir avec les cellules qui sont
dans notre corps et elle va leur dire de
s'activer pour aller réparer un organe
ou un tissu
en fait dans notre corps on en a plein
des molécules bioactives dans nos
différentes y elles ont un rôle
important pour aider notre corps à se
développer
quand on est bébé mais aussi à se
réparer quand on est adulte au sein de
nos zones les principales protéines
bioactives s'appelle les bonnes morpho
genetic pautex bmp c'est leur petit
minet alors je vous ai mis ici leur
structure personnellement je la trouve
très belle
elle a des rubans des feuillets et puis
si vous regardez un petit peu certaines
personnes trouvent qu'elles ressentent
un papillon ces protéines en fait ça
fait déjà à peu près on va dire 45 ans
qu'elles ont été découvertes par le
professeur ulrich aux états unis qui a
montré que si on extrayait ces protéines
de loos puis qu'on allait les implanté
sous un muscle alors un nouvel os était
capable de se reformer là où finalement
n'en attend pas
de nos jours elles sont utilisées par
les cliniciens par les chirurgiens
orthopédiques aussi en maxillo faciale
mais dans certaines situations bien
précises notamment des fractures du
tibia difficile et aussi des fractures
de colonne vertébrale ce que fait le
chirurgien c'est qu'il apprend d'une
éponge naturelle il un bib la protéine
sur l'eponge et il va l'utiliser à 6
cependant actuellement ces protéines bmp
on ne sait pas les faire interagir comme
elles sont naturelles n'interagissent
pas avec des implants qui eux sont
inertes donc un grand challenge
technique qui est étudiée par denon
groupe de chercheurs et entreprises est
d'arriver à délivrer ces protéines de
bmp par des implants au sein de notre
équipe nous avons eu une idée pour
associer les implants à ces protéines
bmp notre idée consiste à déposer infime
à base de polymères naturels des
polymères que l'on trouve déjà dans nos
propres tissus
de les déposer à la surface de l'implant
ce film est en fait de polymères
naturels
il va pouvoir interagir avec les bmp il
valait piéger les pmp vont pouvoir
pénétrer dans le film puis elles vont
ensuite donc pouvoir être présenté à la
surface de l'implant alors je sais que
j'aimerais bien vous montrer ce film
mais en fait il est très difficile à
voir parce qu'il est très fin il fait à
peu près 100 fois moins que l'épaisseur
d'un cheveu
vous imaginez donc là pour le voir
on a mis un petit colorant vert ça nous
permet de voir qu'il épouse parfaitement
la forme d'un plan maintenant on est des
chercheurs donc chez nous les a par des
appareils un peu plus puissant on peut
prendre un microscope spéciale qui va
nous permettre de voir à haute
résolution la surface de l'implant qui
est très rugueuse et le film qui épouse
parfaitement la surface de l'implant une
fois que l'implant recouvert du film est
implanté dans notre corps cela va
pouvoir activer des cellules souches et
leur dire de régénérer l'os à la surface
de 1 pl
la premier point qui était important
pour nous était de voir si vraiment ces
protéines avait la capacité d'induire la
formation d'un nouvel os quand elles
sont déposées sur l'implant pour cela on
a eu l'idée de prendre un petit cylindre
poreux en titane qui est un matériau qui
est très largement utilisé en chirurgie
orthopédique et dentaires donc voyez ce
que vous voyez ici c'est un cylindre
avec une tranche un petit peu comme une
tranche dans un gâteau vous pourrez me
dire que ça ressemble un petit peu à des
barreaux d'une prison puis on pourrait
dire ça tombe bien puisqu'on veut piéger
notre protéines bmp donc on a fait la
même expérience que le professeur orist
on a pris ce cylindre recouvert du film
qu'on a été placée dans un muscle puis
huit semaines après on a extrait le
sinaï et on a regardé par une technique
qui nous permet de marquer l'os en rose
qu'est ce qu'il ressortait voilà ce que
ça a donné
lorsque vous pouvez voir c'est du rose
partout partout à l'intérieur des ports
cela veut vraiment dire que le film est
bio actifs et qu'il a été capable
d'induire la formation dos
c'était vraiment une première étape
importante je dois dire qu'après on a eu
de la chance car on a rencontré petit
peu par hasard lors d'une formation
scientifique
un chirurgien le professeur bettega qui
travaille aussi à chu de grenoble il son
métier c'est de réparer les os de la
face du visage donc avec lui on a conçu
une nouvelle expérience pour aller
tester dans un petit animal si on
pouvait réparer un fémur cassé donc ce
que vous voyez ici c'est à nous de fémur
dans lequel en fait il y a un gros trou
sur à peu près un tiers de sa longueur
donc vous imaginez c'est énorme
un trou comme ça il ne se répare pas
tout seul si on le fixe avec un implant
en polymère sous forme d'un petit tube
creux au mieux on peut le maintenir
est ce qu'on peut voir ici sur l'image
de droite c'est qu'en fait au bout de
deux mois on voit tout
jour 1 trop alors ne cherchez pas avoir
l'implant parce qu'il n'est pas sur
cette image sur une radio ne peut pas
avoir un plan mais par contre on voit
bien que le trou est toujours là
maintenant si on met le film bioactifs
au bout de la même période deux mois on
voit que l'os c'est complètement
reformer mais encore mieux que ça ce
qu'on a pu voir c'est que la formation 2
c'était extrêmement rapide
au bout d'une à deux semaines le défaut
était reformer donc pour nous ça c'est
vraiment un résultat majeur
ça va être le point de départ pour
d'autres études et désormais nous visons
à réaliser une réparation d'un défaut ce
dans un gros animal un défaut de la face
et à terme bien sûr nous souhaitons
pouvoir guérir des patients
ce film il a aussi fallu lui donner un
petit nom et en réfléchissant en
discutant on s'est dit tiens un os qui
se régénère quelque part c'est un homme
heureux
et puis ma fille m'a dit bah tiens à
clapet à pissos sauf qu'en français
s'adonnent à pissos
donc ces fines ce qu'on sait ce qu'on
savait déjà avec ces protéines bmp ce
qu'elles sont capables de réparer le ça
c'est pas nouveau
en revanche nous on apporte trois
nouvelles choses d'une part le film il
peut être couvert sur pleins type
d'implant différents quelle que soit la
forme de l'implant quelle que soit la
nature du matériau et c'est un plan
comme on l'a vu ils sont déjà très
largement utilisé en chirurgie en
orthopédie en maxillo-faciale et aussi
en dentaire deuxièmement le fait que le
film soit déposé à la surface de
l'implant ça va permettre une délivrance
très localisées de la protéine bmp et
donc à l'os de se reformer au contact de
l'appelant et enfin troisièmement la
dose de bmp que l'on utilise elle est en
fait très faible et ça ça va permettre
d'avoir un coût du traitement médical
qui ne soit qu'ils soient pas cher alors
ces travaux vous l'avez compris ils sont
à l'interface entre deux domaines
d'un côté le domaine des matériaux et de
l'autre côté le domaine de la biologie
dans notre équipe nous faisons aussi des
travaux fondamentaux pour avancer dans
ces deux domaines côté matériaux on
cherche à mieux contrôler et
spatialement la délivrance de cette
protéine côté biologie nous cherchons à
comprendre comment les cellules souches
vont répondre à cette protéine et
s'activer pour former le nouvel os et
puis ces protéines bmp pour l'instant
nous nous avons surtout travaillé sur
une protéine qui s'appelle la bmp 2 mai
dans notre corps nous en avons plein
environ 35 et qui vont porter des petits
noms 4 6 9
ce sont comme ça que les scientifiques
et ap ces protéines elles soient
impliqués dans le développement et la
réparation de plein d'organes différents
alors je vais pas et voulait montrer
tous mais ici je voudrais illustré
notamment dans le cartilage dans les
muscles
qui sont souvent très proches des eaux
mais qui sont importants pour réparer
leur mais aussi dans le développement du
cerveau ou encore le développement du
coeur et la formation des vaisseaux
le fait de pouvoir localiser les bmp
avec un film et un biomatériau pourra
nous aider à aller réparer d'autres
organes au final ça me fait penser un
petit peu à nos papillons les papillons
ils ont tous la même forme mais ils ont
des couleurs différentes
ils font partie d'une grande famille ils
ont une capacité à se transformer nous
notre papillon bioactifs en plus de la
transformation
il permet une régénération